se trata de la sentencia más larga
derivada de la toma del Capitolio de
Estados Unidos en enero de 2021
Steward Road fundador del grupo de
extrema derecha outkeepers deberá pasar
18 años en prisión anticipamos mucho más
que una sentencia de 18 años no es que
esté de acuerdo con la sentencia pero
anticipé mucho más Road fue condenado
por orquestar un complot que buscaba
mantener al presidente Joe biden fuera
de la Casa Blanca tras las elecciones de
2020 el militante fue encontrado
culpable por rebelión y conspiración
sediosa siendo el primero en ser
sentenciado por ese delito además el
juez acordó aplicar penas agravantes Por
terrorismo algo inédito para los
involucrados en el asalto del Capitolio
su equipo legal aseguró que apelará la
decisión
creemos que tenemos una buena apelación
en camino esperamos con interés la
apelación el proceso de apelación y
apoyamos firmemente a Stuart Rose no
creemos que sea una amenaza para la
sociedad no creemos en absoluto
en la audiencia El juez lo catalogó como
un peligro para Estados Unidos y también
para la democracia el acusado por su
parte dijo sin pruebas que era un preso
político roads tiene 58 años nació en
Texas y se licenció de la facultad de
derecho deile fue paracaidista del
ejército comenzó su carrera en la Corte
Suprema de Arizona una que dejó para
fundar a los keepers hace más de 10 años
ahora la condena de roads marca un hito
en la investigación sobre el asalto del
Capitolio una decisión que podría abrir
el camino a sentencias más severas en el
hecho que marcó la historia democrática
de Estados Unidos